but um yeah man Asian nights never
really took off she's taken off yeah
yeah killing the game yeah I just saw
the beginning of the special she says
there's a rumor going around then every
agent in town is here tonight oh that
was yeah let me ask you about Netflix
now you have a half-hour yes you did it
already
no no jewel for June 4th certainly
shouldn't they have given you an hour
let me tell you sir no let me tell you
something let me tell you something okay
and you don't have to speak
I'll speak okay and I I'm on love I mean
I you know I don't know Netflix at all I
would love to be in business with them
one day it's a great company but let me
just say this is is that I know that you
showcased a couple of times for them and
then I had heard through the end this
could be wrong that they weren't really
gonna give you a special and then they
gave you a half-hour and I just want to
say this is that regardless of that
you're a [ __ ] monster you are a
genuine monster of a comedian I've seen
you you're one of those guys that if I
have to follow you I literally would be
scared I would do it and I'll be able to
handle myself you know a professional
you know I mean but let me tell you this
it would be like all right how are you
gonna open I guess I would have to
strategize it all right I'm gonna not
tell a joke in the first 45 seconds all
right I'm gonna just get try to get the
audience you know I mean I would have to
think it through sometimes I want to
mostly when IFIF they follow up somebody
at The Comedy Store I don't think about
it I just go up and just do it you know
but this guy is a genuine beast and to
me it's a given right but you know but
congratulations on the 30 minute listen
Bobby okay I went to jail for a second
than you
I know did you ever see Molly's game
mm-hmm just sailing Molly's game when
the father talks to the daughter and he
goes I did a couple things right like
that's all you do in your life we do a
couple of things right everything else
we do is [ __ ] wrong think about how
long we become fuck-ups more how long
will we fuck-ups four-block what we did
and but think of it that what main is
going to the comedy store what made us
showcase form it see what made us gonna
be improv that Tuesday and Budd Friedman
was gonna be there we made some good
choices I'm lucky just to be here his
Netflix said no do you think I would go
home and cry and I wouldn't give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] I know but at 55 just
the fact no no no no but I'm selling
tickets I'm still at the comedies no no
no no that I have a daughter but I don't
do drugs yes yes reefer I love my reefer
do what you want got a [ __ ] xanax
I'll pop that [ __ ] name the
tiger watch your heart but yeah
sometimes you never but you get anxiety
I can advise you the [ __ ] zanuck can
I guess you won't get anxiety I'm very
okay you found saying I'm grateful I
won't ever say get it I'm buddy full I
want to just say that's can I just say
this say it all right find out [ __ ]
now because I'm gonna tell you this
right now okay it's like this it's like
um you know I don't know these kids that
get these things what's fine I'm happy
for everyone that gets it okay but there
are just certain people right that is
just a given
all right you did 25 years of time into
this thing all right and you were always
in it you were never like some of these
guys yeah I I went away for ten years I
came back you know doesn't that this guy
was like me we were in the pocket when
do I always see you why because it's not
because I mean I like seeing you but
it's because you and I have never quit
we never quit yeah we're always just out
there he is he's just a part of my
reality because him and I are both guys
that refuse to leave the game got
nowhere to go we're like rich again I
have to go do not know what
I go to mountaintops I can go to cities
all over the world you would have
somewhere to go you would have gone
already
nobody here he puts up with this [ __ ]
abuse who puts up with this people
choosing us Netflix not giving you a
special but you following Paul Mooney
for a year who the [ __ ] today to decide
that's why we're so lucky you and I have
right that no other comic at one meal
are you ready for this you know what you
and I are one
why are you have the Air Force the [ __ ]
you have my name is we are the Navy
SEALs [ __ ] gets danger
danger it gets danger than a VC okay
real Mitzi shore hand-picked that'll
never ever happen again
so who the [ __ ] is anybody to judge me
is there a picture of me on improv not
really there's not a pic you don't see
me and on any shows getting interviewed
by Conan you know there's another thing
that's interesting yeah I go to Facebook
right or my Instagram whatever social
media and I'll scroll through like you
know these younger guys on Conan and all
these Jimmy Kimmel all these things
that's great and then it always in my
backup hands like I'm on a show now
right network so they have that up front
every year to year to up front so you've
had so far right - yeah do they invite
Bobby now they have never been there and
all they talk about is diversity and
yeah let me I'm on the show which is
great that's good and that was great but
you know it's like relax just for laughs
never been no no yeah but there you've
never been to LA Montreal never never
even they said they didn't like that
which I did with my hand
[Laughter]
it was a happy one here Bruce Hill while
I remember one year he came out to see
me like six times and the last time was
a sec distance is no way and I remember
my manager Abby I'm still with her shake
ya sweetie I'm sorry - no go again this
year and just remember gone have you
been with ad before 20-plus and who's
left with Abby
no one else loyal just you I've been
with Matt Blake for as long as the same
thing I don't leave my people that's
amazed
I'm loyal I'm loyal oh so that's it yeah
I see people switching camps I don't
like it I don't like really [ __ ]
[Music]